c'est une tradition à montigny le
bretonneux comme lors de chaque rentrée
le vélo club de la ville organise sa
fête du vélo du 11 au 13 septembre
quatre circuits vtt sont proposées au
public ce samedi des courses loisirs
dont 1 18 et 1 25 km étaient au
programme
le parcours donc le bois du manet
changarnier domaines port royal et ils
vont avoir ravitaillement qui va se
situer à mi parcours à peu près une
quinzaine de kilomètres où ils vont
pouvoir se restaurer un petit bois sont
un petit sachet sucré et après ils
reviendront ici où ils recevront une de
nouveau une petite collation pour finir
la journée
cette année pour cette 28e édition 4 120
coureurs se sont inscrits pour
participer au rendez-vous loisirs du
samedi malgré les conditions sanitaires
du moment et il perd important de toute
façon j'avais pratiquement tous les ans
je suis un abonné à cette journée
sympathique et donc je viens tous les
ans il ya deux ou trois ans la dernière
fois qu'on l'avait fait cette course on
était fini on avait terminé bon dernier
parce qu'on avait pris beaucoup de
plaisir à
à regarder le paysage et à vivre
vraiment cette beauté dans le 78 donc
depuis je retourne avec mon ami qui me
traîne souvent j'aime bien rouler avec
le vélo c'est drôle candidat fort s ab
bosse partout et
aller en forêt un vélo c'est forcément
écolo et faire des randonnées encore
plus le dimanche le rendez-vous affiché
complet 500 sportifs se sont élancés sur
des raids compétition de 62 à 75 km
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition